paid social marketing is another way to
get your product in front of valuable
customers now you're probably already
using social media to engage as a
community for free but when you want to
drive customer acquisition directly you
can consider buying paid marketing on
social media LinkedIn Facebook Twitter
Instagram snapchat StumbleUpon Pinterest
are all among some of the biggest names
in paid social marketing right now now
there are a few things you should think
about when paying for social media
marketing first you need to understand
how the different ads are sold because
each network does it differently for
example LinkedIn and Facebook will have
you pay by impression on the other hand
Twitter is going to have you pay based
on engagements so I can optimize the
design of your ad for smart phones
social media is overwhelmingly consumed
on mobile devices over half of Facebook
users visit the site on a mobile device
and Twitter users spend 80% of their
time on the mobile devices so you want
to keep that in mind with your messaging
your ads should be short and to the
point your ads should also link directly
to the mobile landing page or directly
to the app you want them to download and
the settings should be aligned to
different mobile platforms you're aiming
for and third have some fun with it
explore what the different platforms
will let you do for example Twitter will
let you pay for tweets that are targeted
by zip code the other hand snapchat lets
you sponsor selfies like this one so
let's hear from a social media marketing
expert my name is Chris morale and I
worked in social media marketing and
content marketing for the last 10 years
or so for brands including Fitbit Clif
Bar Sony Playstation and now here at
Udacity when you're thinking about
starting with social media there's some
really important things to consider I
think first and foremost know your
audience I can't stress that enough go
and do research on your audience's on
each social platform dig into analytics
dig into Twitter analytics Facebook
analytics anything you can to get a
really good sense of your audience make
sure you're constantly listening to what
your audience is saying this will give
you a really great perception of your
audience and exactly who you're trying
to market to you with paid social the
target audiences for each social Channel
are going to vary and I think the more
that your app or product develops and
the more time you spend in each channel
you're going to realize that each
audience has its different unique
characteristics for example two
might be really great for customer
support and Instagram and Pinterest
might be great for sharing organic photo
assets brand images and just really
great engaging content it's important to
really know your demographics do some
research use free tools use anything at
your disposal to discover age gender and
any important demographic info that you
think is gonna help create a better and
more successful ad campaign when you
start setting up campaigns you're also
gonna notice that the big platforms
Facebook Twitter and LinkedIn they're
really competitive something to consider
if you want to stay ahead of the curve
is to advertise on emerging channels so
think Instagram and Pinterest think
snapchat these aren't gonna be as
competitive as channels like Twitter
Facebook Linkedin and you might get
better returns success on channels like
Instagram and Pinterest might be as
simple as creating experiences and ads
that feel real to the user they feel
like organic posts from a brand and not
an advertisement